[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the 45th President
of the United States accompanied by
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much everybody the
Sandman my wife asked me why the Sandman
just tell me our first lady I said
because he put the batter to sleep bread
The Sandman a lot of people don't know
that but the Yankee fans know that we've
watched it for a long time thank you all
for coming the first lady and I are
delighted to welcome you to the White
House today we present our nation's
highest civilian honor the Presidential
Medal of Freedom to American baseball
legend maybe the greatest pitcher of all
time it's a big argument is he the
greatest pitcher of the greatest
reliever well the reliever we want but
there's a real question he may be the
greatest pitcher the history of baseball
Mariano Rivera when you hear the stats
you'll understand exactly why I say that
Mariano I want to congratulate you on
this really extraordinary achievement
thank you it's on behalf of this whole
country thank you very much for the
great job
[Applause]
we're delighted to be joined by our Vice
President Mike Pence and his wonderful
wife Karen thank you very much Karen
thank you along with many of the members
of our very distinguished and
hardworking and very very successful
cabinet thank you all for being here
thank you thank you cabinet we're all so
grateful to be joined by Mariano's wife
Clara Thank You Clara
Thank You Clara his three sons Yaphet
yasiel and Marianas daughter-in-law
ELISA thank you very much thank you all
for being here it's so great and his
longtime manager one of the great
players and a great great manager Joe
Torre where's Jeff
a great player too and chief operating
officer of the New York Yankees lawn
trust thank you thank you long good luck
go get it
we could use him in the bullpen maybe
and that would be good that would
guarantee it
good luck great season you've had
tremendous season Mariano was born the
son of a fishing boat captain on the
coast of Panama he learned to play
baseball on the mudflats of the Pacific
with a cardboard love a bad fashioned
from a tree branch and a ball made out
of rock string and tape there wasn't a
lot of money for playing baseball he
excelled at the sport at the age of 18
he started playing in the country's top
adult lake in a critical game with his
team losing badly the coach called him
over and asked Mariano to do something
that he had never really done before
could you pitch Mariano mo insisted that
he could not but when he took the mound
an amazing thing happened the crowd
witnessed an incredible performance
his opponents did not get a single run
for the rest of the game and a legend
was starting his team won an epic
comeback victory big deal at that time
and after that as teammates contacted a
scout and told him that he had a tryout
in Panama City with the world's most
famous baseball dynasty the New York
Yankees with barely enough money for the
bus ride home
Mariano set out on a journey that would
define his life and inspire countless
millions around that lo at his first
tryout in worn-out shoes and a borrowed
glove Mariano threw nine fast balls it
was the only pitch he knew how to throw
after a few more tryouts the yankees
offered him a contract to play their
farm team the Gulf Coast Yankees do you
remember that Mariano the Gulf Coast
were they a good team not bad right
he got in an airplane and came back to
America a few months later in August
1990 mariana threw his first no-hitter
that year he had an average er a of 0.7
teen so that doesn't mean one that means
like one seventeenth of one that's not a
lot did you lose how do you lose a game
well I guess you score no runs right boy
oh boy
in 52 innings he had point 17 which is
unheard of over 22 games soon thereafter
Mariano married Clara which was an even
more important thing for him to do and
truly and he said it many times you are
the love of his life you know that you
feel that right I hope he tells you that
they will soon celebrate their 20th
wedding anniversary congratulations to
our
after five years playing in the minors
in 1955 Mariano made it to the big
leagues in his second season with the
Yankees Mariano delivered 130 strikeouts
in less than 100 and eight innings while
facing 425 batters he allowed only one
home run with an ER a of 2.09 the
Yankees made him a closer for the 1997
season that's when it really started
happening that year he accidentally
threw a pitch he had never thrown before
then he tried it several more times
again and again kept working and at the
last second his fastball it was really
an incredible thing became the cutter he
had suddenly developed that lethal pitch
which are people throwing that pitch
today because I've never noticed they
seemed to they don't have your success I
can tell you right they don't they may
be throwing it but it doesn't work quite
the same way and many players would come
to consider it the greatest pitch ever
in baseball
it would break many records and many
bats in a 1999 game against the Atlanta
Braves his cutter snapped a big strong
guy Ryan Klesko I know him well as a
player he's a big powerful guy and he
broke his bat three times in one plate
appearance that has to be like a record
in 2001 Mariano's heavy fearsome pitch
destroyed 44 bats in less than 81
innings and I used to say I tell people
I've never seen a guy break so many bats
it's called a heavy heavy pitch and I
asked Mariano why and he really didn't
know just was the way it was right it's
just the way it happened it's from God
it's from God when he retired the
Minnesota Twins presented him with what
would become one of the most prized
possessions a chair made out of their
shattered bats
in 1998 1999 and 2000 World Series
championships
Mariano closed out three consecutive
World Series victories and delivered 14
strikeouts and seven saves he gave up
only two runs 259 batters and you got to
remember you're playing against the best
team so this isn't like palying the low
level this is the best team and he had a
very unusual trait he did better against
the best teams and he did incredibly in
the playoffs game after game when his
entrance music Enter Sandman filled the
arena fans went wild knowing that the
game was all but over his dominance on
the mound mesmerized fans teammates and
unfortunately for them it mesmerised the
competitors in Game seven of the 2003
American League Championship Mariano
entered at the top of the ninth with the
score tied five to five he held off the
Boston Red Sox for three straight
innings without giving up a single run
helping secure the series for the
Yankees he was named the Series MVP not
surprising
one of the most memorable moments of
Marianas career was the final game of
the old Yankee Stadium this is a last
game in Yankee Stadium when he took his
place in history as the final man to
pitch in that shrine to American
baseball and I spent many a day in that
Stadium and night and it was special
with Moe on the mound for the ninth
inning
not a single hitter from the Baltimore
Orioles made it to first base he secured
yet one more Yankee victory and that day
the old stadium became the house that
Ruth Built and that Rivera closed out
over the course of 19 seasons you have
to hear this to believe it
I didn't even know it I knew he was the
best but this is crazy
Mariano broke the major league baseball
record for the most games finished and
saves made he has the best ER a earned
run average in the past 100 years
2 point 2 1 in the regular season and an
even more astounding point 70 that's
less than one run in the postseason when
again you play the best teams these are
the hot teams these are the teams that
are just beating up everybody and you
had less than one run point 7 it's
amazing he made more than 2 times as
many saves as the next best pitcher in
postseason and a true clutch pitcher he
was always the best against the most
talented hitters amazingly the 527
batters he faced in postseason games hit
only two home runs and scored only 13
runs against him I think you guys want
him quickly we have to get him get him
in uniform you know you're getting ready
to sign him up blonde
Mariano helped lead the Yankees to five
World Series victories was named the
World Series MVP in 1999 and this year
he became the first person unanimously
elected to the Baseball Hall of Fame
unanimous that one hurt
[Applause]
so just out of curiosity Babe Ruth was
not unanimously elected babe the babe
didn't make it what was his problem he
did pretty good too
you mean babe was not unanimous well he
had some other difficulty so yeah that's
pretty good Mariano that's I've heard
first unanimously the babe huh
we love the babe what a swing to babe
had that old corkscrew swing right
nobody could figure him out either
throughout Mariano's incredible career
he remained a humble man guided by a
deep Christian faith that inspires
everyone around him as he says he has
always remembered that the Lord doesn't
care about wealth or fame or the number
of saves somebody has we are all
children of God and the Lord cares about
the goodness and love in our hearts
that's all well well that is different
than the babe I would say I don't know
if the baby ever said that
that's pretty sure he didn't maybe in
his last year he said it nearly two
decades ago
Mariano founded the Mariano Rivera
Foundation which has provided hundreds
of scholarships for underprivileged
children along with school supplies for
countless students and is currently
building a learning and community center
in New Rochelle New York where I can
tell you from being in New York what
you've done in New Rochelle has been
incredible incredible after retiring
from baseball Mariano and his wife built
an evangelical church and today Clara is
its pastor I'm gonna have to come listen
to you sometime I could use it that's
good Mariano was naturalized as a US
citizen in 2015 and of course he serves
as co-chair of the President's Council
on sports fitness and nutrition Mariano
Rivera has made extraordinary
contributions to American sports culture
and society he is the most dominant
relief pitcher in the history of
baseball and more than that he has lived
the
American Dream and shines as an example
of American greatness for all to see
and I'd now like to ask the military aid
to come forward and present Mariano
Rivera with the Presidential Medal of
Freedom and before we do the actual
presentation I'd like to have Mariano
just say a few words and I know most of
those words are going to be addressed to
his family because I know how he feels
about his family nobody loves their
family more than Mariano please Maya Wow
amazing mr. president thank you for so I
would like to say thank God for a
wonderful day you know always be here in
presence in a mr. president thank you
for all those words and remarks the
first lady thank you depends Karen thank
you for being all of you for being here
present but my wife my kids and my
family's rest of the family friends
without you guys supporting the prayers
we got from now mr. mr. t mr. Joe Torre
benefit for a lot of those prayers
and for me it's an honor and a privilege
to receive this a world is a matter of
freedom which amia all ideal yes
try to be the best and do the best for
them for America you know one thing that
I had to remark is one remark when I
came here in 1990 I came to Tampa Dean
spoke no English
I mean speak now forget about 1990 you
know the reason what I did that because
I mean in the team there were a lot of
players that spoke Spanish so I got a
little comfortable and then try a little
bit to learn the language my second year
in baseball I was in Greenville North
Carolina where most of the people didn't
speak any Spanish especially my team is
the even I was a little younger so the
guy that spoke Spanish and the team will
hang out with the older guys and I was
left I think I was hanging out with the
guys friend of my team Cooper and
another way guy Bob just to like I asked
because I was frustrated times could I
go to bed crying no because the game but
because I was frustrated because I
couldn't speak the language I couldn't
speak English so therefore I told those
two teams of mine I said I don't care
how much you laugh and I don't care how
much you make fun of me but please I
give you the permission to laugh and do
that but teach me teach me the right way
by my surprise they never laugh at me
and they teach me by the end of the year
I was able to communicate with my
manager with my teammates and I was the
happiest man in baseball and from that I
would say that my career took off and I
was able to realize that I can do
something for others because I knew
the language now I can relate with
someone that's going through the same
process that I've been but at the same
time there yes learning English is the
first thing that we should do and I did
and for that being a being American
I'm so proud an honor there are coming
from a small town beautiful town
beautiful country called Panama and live
with my family here and understand the
language paying everything that we go
through I'm proud to be an American
[Applause]
during his 19 seasons in Major League
Baseball Mariano Rivera established
himself as the greatest relief pitcher
of all time signed by the New York
Yankees in 1990
mr. Rivera went on to become a 13 time
all-star and five-time World Series
champion he was the first player in the
history of the sport
to be elected unanimously into the
National Baseball Hall of Fame off the
field through the Mariano Rivera
foundation he has helped provide
children in need with an education
empowering them to achieve a better
future the United States proudly honors
Mariano Rivera for being a legend of the
game of baseball and for his commitment
to strengthening America's communities
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]